hey everyone thanks for joining us for
the 2021 canadian country music award
nomination announcement i'm cheryl
hickey host of et canada i am so happy
to announce the ccmas will take place
live from london ontario's budweiser
gardens on monday november 29th so
get your cowboy boots ready and saddle
up for what i know we know will be a
very exciting show now tonight on at
canada we will be announcing the
nominees for album of the year so make
sure you tune in at 7 30 p.m eastern on
global tv but right now i'd like to
welcome platinum selling duo and our
good friends the requirements to help
you announce the nominees this year
jenna and stu how are you ah we're so
good thank you so much for having us
this is such an honor to see you and to
announce something so special to us
[Applause]
stu does jenna make you call her the
engaged one like all the time now now
that she's engaged
right i'm not even involved but i'm
supposed to call her the fiance we're
actually like um there's instead of a
duo there's three of us now that's right
love it congratulations now you two have
taken home a few ccma awards what went
through your minds when you won did it
feel like a dream 100 every single time
every year that we're invited to go
to the ccmas is such a dream come true
we used to go to the ccmas and sit in
the back row and watch people perform
and watch them win awards so to get on
stage and receive awards is
everything you could ever dream of so
fantastic okay so let's see if we can
make some more dreams come true right
now so jenna kick things off all right
the nominees for rising star are
sean austin
andrew hyatt
tyler joe miller
robin ottolini and tim and their glory
boys
and the nominees for alternative country
album of the year are
after midnight kaylee mccullough
agriculture tragic or blund
the ride
ryan lindsey
who i am cory marx
and one of our friends without people
donovan woods
so good okay so the nominees for
interactive artist or group of the year
are lindsay l
aaron goodman
james barker band
nice horse
and the red cloth
that's amazing
okay the nominees for male artists of
the year are
dean brody
jade eagleson
brett kissel
tyler joe miller and dallas smith what a
lineup that's a big one that's a great i
know right it's so great all right well
that is a stacked category for sure okay
the nominees for group or duo of the
year are
high valley
hunter brothers
tim and the glory boys
the washboard union and the breakfast
wow you guys really set yourself really
just you blessed to laugh you really
didn't like them are you shocked are you
surprised honestly to see our name up
there is that is just
it's everything it's so cool yeah all
right stu you're next
the nominees for female artist of the
year are
to neil arts
lindsay l jess moskalook
mackenzie porter
and tamil towns
all right talk about amazing women okay
the nominees for single of the year are
grew up on that high
grew valley grew up on them like a man
dallas smith gonna chase you like a boy
looking like a man no truck song tim
hicks
can't help myself dean brody in the
wreck laws
two nominations in one category i mean
what does that feel like i
there's no words it's like this is
surreal i can't believe this so exciting
okay let's keep things going i'm going
to need your help with the next one it
is the nominees for amazon music amazon
alexa fans choice
neil arts
brody and
jade eagleson plus
high valley rhett kissel and tyler joe
and let's not forget
mackenzie porter
dallas smith tiniel towns
and
[Music]
okay how about you take the next
category all right the nominees for
writers of the year this is a big one
patricia conroy esther dean andrew de
roberts dave haywood charles kelly shane
macanally
madeline merlot tina pearl hillary scott
ryan tedder dave pump and that is for
the song champagne night performed by
lady
[Music]
daniel tashin to neil towns
for the song come as you are performed
by tomorrow
every time you take your
time aaron goodfin ed hill jimmy richie
for the song every time you take your
time
performed by aaron goodman that white
t-shirt looks good on it
[Music]
but certainly not please is zack abend
jess moskvaloo and liz rose for the song
matt dot performed by jess
amazing all right the nominees for prs
guitars video of the year are
drinking songs mackenzie porter now it's
just another one of my joking songs
hunter brothers
make a life not a living breath kissel
i'm trying to make a life not a living
map yes
and want me back
[Music]
okay jen and stu do you want to do the
honors and announce entertainer of the
year absolutely i do i really do this is
a big big award this is the award
nominees for entertainer of the year are
dean brody brett kissel
mackenzie porter
and
dallas
wait you guys missed one there's a name
missing from the list all right it's the
reckless yes youtubers
you're the entertainer of the year
congratulations
okay what is going on in your brain
right now oh
prs guitar it seemed right
[Music]
the nominations aren't even fully
announced yet and so far you are leading
the pack with six artist nominations
six what's that feel like that's the
most we've ever had before that's like
head and shoulders i'm gonna cry it's
crazy it's been the craziest year it's
an honor to even just be beside those
people and i think that is just what we
want to do we want to get on stage and
entertain thanks so much for watching
everyone and do not forget to tune in 7
30 p.m eastern tonight on global as we
announce the nominees for album of the
year at the end of et canada and of
course head on over to ccma.org for
details surrounding the canadian country
music awards presented by
td thanks for watching everybody
[Music]